hello hello today we're gonna carry on
playing fran wow it's been a little
while but I'm really really really
already really looking forward to
finally finishing this and today we're
going to go back to being human we're
gonna be a human again we're not gonna
be a true anymore guys progress okay so
we've got to go to the mechanical doll
to find the Wizards wand see I remember
this do you if you don't you can watch
the last episode beginning yep there's
the wand where how did how we've been
here so many times and it was never
holding a wand I see the wand see how
this works okay so we need to get the
one to us by moving his hands the
smoothest hands out the way that one's
still in the way yeah maybe in a
different season
doesn't seem to be making any difference
whatsoever but call music so let's just
keep it like this oh he caught her with
this other hand okay so I'm making him
pass the wand around hey see cool right
let's yeah let's let's go back alright
sir I've got your wand it's a very cool
wand here's your one sir with it Oh
magnificent magnificent splendid you did
it really but where are the stones can I
borrow them I can't lend you this Jones
these stairs are very very special what
i can do is place the students are the
lots of the door but you you are the
only one who can turn the key and
actually over at all oh I see the cane
told me he would show me where the door
is ah then we should go and talk with
him did you think hmm wait I suspect you
can't return home looking for like a
tree yeah that's the thing oh I almost
forgot yes you're right can you bring my
human body back yes I can this is
exciting i haven't got listen hundreds
of years let's make a human yes give me
your clothing i need to smell it yes and
my clothing let me smell this this can
work we will make a human oh this is so
exciting good now go to the center of
the star of our Thursday
and think about your body your head your
leg and your other leg Oh God if I did
this in real life I would mess it up I'd
be like so thinking about the body but
then i'd probably think of like a dog
leg and a horse face and it would just
be awful you can make yourself look
however you wanted to do pretty cool i
would write myself a bit taller randomly
selected elements find your path to your
true essence become Fran the human now
did it work
yeah I think of what huh are you all
right what happened is it done oh wow
thank you so much sir you really are a
great wizard yes that's my name great
wizard because of the greatness mmm I
think we have to go to the king oh I
think you have to go to King now can you
show me the door yes I'll be right there
I have to finish something else
stupidbunny trick ah can I help you with
the bunny trick I just realized it's a
severed hand has it always been a
severed hand probably yes look right
there okay I'll go to the castle that's
not the king everything is fine it feels
like heaven what are you leave mr.
midnight alone is your head playing with
you again can't you see yourself in the
mirror I'm not you I'm not let mr.
midnight go now we killed the traitors
because that's what he is friend don't
you see how is a cat a traitor oh it's
got this eyes for mum Pan's Labyrinth my
kitty is not the traitor he promised me
to be by my side he promised as your
mummy and daddy did you promise to take
good care of you wake up Fran
rounded by traitors they couldn't help
being wear it leave me alone leave my
friend alone and the only one you have
friend I'm the only one who's always by
your side let's get rid of this traitor
what do you say let's be happy let's be
so very happy Wow
it's so dark yet right it's very strange
fine what's wrong with you wait pan
what's wrong why are you crying I'm
crazy sir I'm totally crazy the doctors
were right but you're not crazy I'm very
sorry that you feel that way you should
be happy now you found the stones you
become a human again that is very great
indeed my dear let me wipe those tears I
don't wonder I don't want to hurt you I
feel like I'm about to do it at any
moment you found I know that I've copped
in love yes I do Fran remember what I
told you if you love you are alive and
that is the only thing that matters you
will always find the power to fight
those monsters in you now let's go open
the gates you can go home yes Judas
where is the eighth
here that's a gate here we are where's
the door oh right have to make it
visible but are you sure you want to go
back I'm sure sir right here we go
Schumer must leave open the secret door
into her reality let the human return
home where's the wizard he said he was
gonna come meet us but he's not here to
say goodbye we're going home oh there he
is right on cue haha z are the king good
day to you i bought the stones so this
is lovely quit you can go home thank you
sir I'm very nervous it will be strange
being far away from you all then don't
leave I can make you a place to stay a
very magical place on us that's nice
wizard she has to leave I received a
message from one of the villa cos she's
not ready oh I see what are you talking
about ready for what come on was it hey
systems we have no time to lose but
ready for what you know what the ville
Acas told you about facing your truth oh
i think i remember well should I yes go
ahead was it's a magic stones create the
lock that only the human can break
done how do we break them it's time for
Fran to be the key you are the only one
who can open this all right let's do dis
is it another puzzle or is it just I
don't know what to do Oh
tada
here we go smell victory you did it burn
you can go home now I'm so excited I
wish I could leave you something so you
can remember me cut off some of your
hair or something we won't forget you
you're a very special creature I almost
forgot Blanche Ross gave me this for you
oh wow what is what is that thank you
tell Polanco's that I wish I could help
him with his wounds I gave my aid
patches to again on the hospital I'll
Talon and don't wipe elantris is better
now okay that was weird he just fell out
of the sky before you return to your
reality you will go through this secret
foods the woods are kind of an invisible
passage between our realities and you
may encounter terrible creatures that
really did you ok but just run they're
quite slow all right you're telling me
this now that's so scary don't worry
you'll do fine it reminds me of them oh
it's a court I was a movie quote it
follows where it's really slow but it's
always coming scary I mr. midnight say
goodbye goodbye gentlemen I had a great
time what a polite kitty I like you very
much goodbye
all right time to run away from some
things that gonna try any as it seems oh
this is cool oh this is cool okay oh
okay Oh died straight away I like these
little mini games that like they had a
lot of fun making this good good good
what I don't know how I'm making those
noises with her oh my god don't let me
Fran don't let me gonna he's gonna eat
your friend is it here it is go go go go
beautiful love the art style so nice to
for part 1 an imaginary friend my
imaginary friend where are they oh my
goodness the door opened Wow interesting
my goodness interesting yo mr. midnight
let's find out where we are think I'll
be back in the woods where we kind of
left off before fan I hope we can find
home soon I'm starving oh no well what's
this on the floor I'm trying to I think
we on the other side of the bridge oh
yeah yes we are back where we were and
then they fell is I remember great let's
keep on going kitty we have to be
careful we've got a pills now as well
are these my pills oh no we don't have
our bills ok so those are her pills
someone's kind of trying to get her to
follow them homes this way apparently
that seems way too convenient to be
there though um I guess is in that
direction ok there's a tree this is a
tree looks perfect but a little
treehouse on oh it does
hmm
try again Oh bulls we go cool I
shouldn't touch the peels bad friend bad
bad okay let's see what we got we here
we go we still got a bloody knife which
is fine we're fine
when you're already here what I wasn't
expecting you until 235 who are you and
as I see it mm-hmm you are not trapped
anymore it's interesting anyway let me
introduce myself I am it word your
faithful friend he's our friend he looks
scary it word do I know you from
somewhere you seem familiar yes i am the
creature of the night we've been playing
together I have to get to meet mr.
midnight back you see really i think i
managed quite well to find my kitty on
my own hey aren't you the one that made
the sisters mad no that was me making
the sisters mad they believed it with me
you see yes because they never looked
into themselves what do you mean by they
never looked into themselves they blame
me instead of facing the fact that their
parents never loved him but I sometimes
mother sisters shall we don't you
recognize me dear friend the wrong man
with the top art I always came by night
and told you stories when you were just
a little baby I came to you after you
imagined me but I'm not imagine her a UC
i'm part of your reality did I imagine
you yeah you're quite familiar I can't
deny that I exist because you exist that
is the truth you were able to imagine me
because I already existed anyway we
don't have time to talk about this right
now actually I'm here to take you home
follow me so do you have my pills of why
did you set a trap if that was you I
can't trust you because you set a trap
and stuff I won't hurt you I'm not made
of darkness I'm your friend hmm all
right you seem nice I'll go with you but
I won't trust you yet that's fine come
on now I have something to show you Wow
he is a tall tall person
yeah he seems harmless wow that's a cool
house behold it would flying machine
what do you think I think it's so cool I
love it has many buttons to push yes
with this gorgeous piece of machinery
I'll take you home well fly as soon as I
fix the details besides us not to 35 yet
why do you need to 35 that sounds great
but why 235 I don't understand it's when
time becomes slower and gives us a
chance to enter the ultra-reality oh
true reality we can travel whatever you
want to go right now we're standing in
the endless limits of the second reality
but you are part of the third reality
you understand oh yes I do understand it
sounds insane but sighs wait until
you're done fixing machine wait of
course not you can help by getting water
and fire berries alright alright sounds
good well great here's my amazing hand
bucket o handmade pocket made for water
it does pretty cool bucket in the fire
berries you realize which bear is to
pick up because of the fire alright but
so can I just ask why do you need the
berries and the water while the berries
are incredibly good fuel they last many
many hours and the water was to get rid
of the pitch the koalas oh come all this
I see I hope they don't come flying
around the machine no I hope they don't
come around the blowing machine okay
enough enough enough church are some
things are still invisible to your eyes
oh yeah of course thank you for my pills
I was trying to catch her pills earlier
but the truck caught me first oh yes
about that I'm sorry I needed to get
your attention somehow why don't you
just say her name okay Fran hi it's ok
so I defeated the truck like in once
second mm-hmm anyway I'll do in the fire
Bros sounds good this is the whole best
part of the game you never know what
you're gonna see and it's always a
creepy why are they using era mi
nutritious I bet I am so gross okay hmm
yeah she gives me shivers whenever I do
that the kind of birds this is grant
whole thing is grand let's go have a
look mr. midnight what is this so much
hair and so shiny so much hair so shiny
much wow where do we
these are the barriers that we need hmm
did we do that oh yeah we've got this
what is this again
wonder why blanches gave me this I can't
open it looks like it's got a password
or something we're about here ah there
the berries what the bloody hell's this
get out get out you are trespassing on
my territory is it alive excuse me I
thought you were dead how can you
possibly think that you have no manners
young lady I'm very sorry you seem to be
your rotten and bloody knee rotten and
bloody I think you'll miss understand
this situation ah why do you say that
mr. moose and some moose but i'm not a
moose I'm an aide Lee worm Oh a deadly
worm no not a deadly worm a deadly worm
I don't go wrong kidding switches I just
get back to the soil we just took them
and don't need any more but i only see
you talking moose where are you Oh down
here creature can't you see me oh there
you is pretty disgusting can I ask why
did you touch the moose in the first
place normally only scavengers with
touch dead animals are you one of course
not i was trying to see if I would climb
on it to reach the fire berries I see I
think it's possible the Moose is still
very sturdy and solid but the fire
berries are on fire you can hurt
yourself yeah I can see the fire but I
have to take them somehow good luck with
that climb on now I'll keep working
thank you sir that don't curtsy thank
you sir yeah how are we going to they're
gonna hurt
so anything here we can use oh okay
maybe we could put water on it whatever
let's just have a look okay so let's get
down hello I those oh wait now this is
Fran hello and there is shiny insects
that get stuck on trees because of what
are those shiny insects that get stuck
on trees because of curiosity we usually
get stuck yes how did you know this
you're not one of us
I've met your kind before I help me get
free ah that that's very nice of you
curiosity can lead us to unexpected
situations yeah I think you're Austin's
good thing but are you stuck not at all
we're just trying to be go ahead the
longest however wow that sounds amazing
good luck I have to go now bye okay
where's water where can I find water
down there
hmm can't reach the water
I need help please would you allow me to
tie this bucket to your beautiful hair
tie a bucket to our hair wyd it sounds
insane oh it's not insane at all i just
did the water I need to use your
beautiful long hair oh please help me
all right we'll help you tie the bucket
real tight ah thank you you're very nice
pull up the whole bucket please nice
done bucket isn't our full of water
thank you shiny insects I will have to
go now home is where some home is
somewhere we all wish to belong but
first home belong somewhere sorry I
didn't really understand the question it
was a rhetorical question I just wanted
to say that you are your own home
welcome yourself inside you will find
many doors to open oh that sounds for
serious and beautiful I try to do that
some other time some other time some
other time just skim the water
yours sweet tempers poem off in my hands
okay well you've got this bloody knife
gonna be very careful oh it's still full
awesome we don't need to go do that
again berries and we got the wallet so i
bought the fire berries they're not on
fire anymore magnificent yes they will
do just fine thank you very much my
darling and here's the water so it would
here's the bucket full of water I got
help from the shiny insects you mean the
Lucifer's yes they are nice but only one
you see them in this reality the very
dangerous if you ever see them in the
fifth reality they can burn you Oh
behind me well I haven't been into the
best way out yet I don't recommend it
what's reasonable there may be the worst
you'll ever experience oh I forgot to
thank you for the water Thank You Fran
our frien it's 230 for the journey will
begin let's go inside let's go fly let's
go flat let's go flat let's go flat you
can fly me to fly to fly we could fly it
weighs up fun big a flower
you don't wanna fight so weird it's 236
we have great possibility of reaching
the target in good condition will soon
be on our way to the third reality are
you excited for her ah tell me tell me
all the things you'll soon understand
the art is not easy to recognize well
that's sounds strange Tom goes as it has
to in all of you to be alive if it all
happen now you'd probably explode I
can't tell me me that the answers I'm
looking for comes me when they want not
exactly you know what I'd rather say
through time you have to install an
experience to understand this means the
answers will come to you when you find
them not what others tell you or how or
where to find them as actually very good
advice it's very good advice I see well
i'm excited now you woke up my curious
illness necessities that's the best
thing I can do you can do for yourself
be curious and you'll always be amazed
but now Fran we have to get things done
talking won't take you home one thing
sir the machine needs some maintenance
and I think you would do incredible work
here are the fire berries and the water
you gather before you'll need them to
get the water put working again ok the
funny information is the vin when you
left feel free to enter bah bah blah
that's why the driver if you have
something to ask I'll be here ok
this music makes me think of forks
you're a little bit strange Fran I
wouldn't really say around your Forks
not the utensils anyway if that's what
you mean ah what the bloody hell look at
this shoes you rip off the sole of your
feet I put it to the bottom of the shoe
what the hell this is gross one foot
with a shoe one but without a shoot us
so creepy okay anyway oh I she'd wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait pills
it where'd you creeping me out so if you
don't like clowns like we're moving on
oh hey hey hey I follows you before okay
that was weird okay reality view ultra
yards of you i xu the fired the chemical
mixture ok ok so just got to put the the
pink and the blue holes somewhere so
what so where's the pink were gay pink
one goes from the middle of the blue one
oh wait oh no i've got them so a 18 to a
little pop in between something or other
i have not a clue hmm I don't know what
I'm doing guys get out of that
oh did you put some stuff in there okay
OST pills oh look it's another version
of fran with long hair she's quite
pretty with long hair nor all those
eyeballs 0 seconds and minutes hours and
days what does that even mean tick-tock
tick-tock I've got to understand you
I've forgot to give myself some love
seconds and minutes hours and days okay
let's check out this room are you
everywhere we can do some theater stuff
yay Oh something's missing need a key oh
I wanted to see a little puppet show not
fat whatever this guy's Hey look Oh the
key as well sweet and it's a key I
wonder what it's for oh she's smiling is
creepy are you are you here to kill it
for it I know why won't you talk to me
I'm very simple I did I hope you can
forgive me they're so creepy why are you
smiling okay let's use this key
in a world made of darkness and light
two little sisters tried to steal each
other's charm but none of the size could
decide if what they were was just all
right me I was angry and Karim sad and
this was because they were both blood Oh
insane little girls insane of their
minds it was the creature of the night
he came always around in dreams or
reality teaching the girls the splendor
of duality but they couldn't understand
it what was just a friend it foot was
the link between darkness and light he
was gray but Clara and Mia only day one
day decided to get rid of it word once
and for all die creature of the night
guy they said but they killed each other
instead dead and gone
the sisters kept complaining about each
other it's all your fault clara del
Golfo via then it would came to visit
for the last time and he said you are
both trapped in the world of
disconnections but i'll give you a
chance the world has been mean to you
they sewed your bodies together to prove
that they could they gave you a mirror
to compare yourselves I'll give you
nothing but what you already have and
just one tiny little chance to
understand the purpose of life
but the clock is ticking you have until
the day a black cat goes missing
and the wells magic door is unlocked the
end oh so that's what happened to the
sisters it's weird noise huh we
understand now sisters it wasn't it word
it wasn't it word it was you you're
crazy but I can kind of understand why
they were sewing you up and stuff look
it's Kings ear okay let's see if we can
just solve this little puzzle quick and
then I think that's enough for this
episode how do we make these things then
yeah that's right whatever this one
ah there's a hose here okay anymore oh
this one here too okay what time what do
i do of these holes is okay um why it
says is a good this one that goes there
oh the green one goes to the bottom cups
okay yes that's right and then I think
this one goes up here yes okay so we've
got the hoses in the workplace we're hos
ready but I don't really know what to do
these afm what is a FM oh we got to find
how are we gonna make that mixture
anyone got some afm we put in here
berries nope this oh ok oh no we need
something to fix that gonna tape anyone
got any tape you got any tape this place
he might have some tape somewhere Oh
tape ok awesome it's gonna fix this and
get this racking wagon and then we can
go back to our our world I should give
myself a hug for being so clever Oh
should you from it's just that a tape
don't know how this works so h2o in
there that one that way with that one
these ups of that that one is that way
oh I need a matchstick for that this is
that way and there's going to be like
this might need a matchstick joy how
many matches do I do here we go perfex
we can follow instructions we are
intelligent people okay I gotta find
this afm we're with the afm be
hmm look bad at bat bad
the fire barriers that aren't on fire
into the VARs ready that SIA phone I
don't know I think I'm doing it dude
doing something to PF and what was it
ar-15 go on and this one's n16 cool
super chemistry master friend Bo I feel
pretty clever actually yay we did it
it's what are you proud Bronn I finally
managed to fix the automatic driver do
you need help nope I did it omas lamp I
did all us to me very well Fran
everything seems to working perfectly
yes everything looks absolutely great
what should we do now sir well I wanted
to ask if you are afraid of rabbits no
there's a little rabbit in one of the
rooms and I'm I'm deeply afraid of it
would you like to help me get rid of it
a rabbit I guess it depends on the
rabbit sir oh my gosh I had the worst
nightmare about a rabbit um I'm gonna
make a video out of it so I'm going to
tell you right now but had the worst
nightmare bear rabbit is it a chocolate
rabbit or one with horns and killer eyes
you have to see for yourself it has a
pink nose in blue boots okay that
doesn't sound too bad it's just sitting
there no blinking no movement staring
all the time sounds very scary brave you
are dear follow me now let's do this
space our fears seriously the bunny in
my dream is the scariest thing ever and
I really want to make a video for
halloween cuz salary was going on I love
Halloween anyway I'm getting off topic
let's just focus on front though um okay
there see its just oh that thing that
thing are you serious but what I see
it's a toy sir I won't move would you
please try make contact with it I don't
dare touch it alright so I'll take the
rabbit and show you there's nothing to
be afraid of maybe I should give it
carrots first just in case okay fine see
it's just a fluffy rabbit nothing to be
afraid of oh you're right friend there
is nothing to be afraid of ah I knew we
can trust him guys that is it for this
episode we've done a lot with you and
again we are on our way to our own
dimension we just traveled through
another and now we're gonna get mr.
midnight back because apparently we
can't rely on Edward it would was not
trustworthy why did we think he was nice
we're too nice ourselves anyway I will
see you in the next episode of a raise
soon I hope you have a lovely day or
evening hi let me be your mommy let me
feel
what are you gonna feed me come to my
side uh mr. midnight don't go towards
there and you will have many new friends
to play with they um they kind of know a
little Jokers